it's an all-girl School except for the
all girls rule and now they'll award a
cap and gown if you only use the right
pronoun Harpeth Hall what a great name
Harpeth come here
it's an elite girls only school in
Nashville aren't they all has changed
its admissions policy to accept
biological males who simply say they're
girls it's the same policy I use to get
free Mai Tais on ladies nights
the school dates back to the 1800s when
biology was far less Advanced and just
relied on physiology instead of Trends
on Twitter but to be honest there was
some gender fluid people back then as
noted in the novel men who identify as
Little Women
foreign
that's pretty funny they actually made
the cover they don't do that on Special
Report they announced the change in a
new gender diversity philosophy emailed
to parents quote any student who
identifies as a girl may apply to our
school students who join and remain at
Harpeth Hall do so because our mission
as a school for girls resonates with
them
the truth is what you feel even if you
feel balls
translation biological males are now
allowed as long as you commit to your
pronoun the letter continues if a
student communicates a desire to be
identified as male or adopt he him
pronouns we recognize that our school
being a girls school May no longer be a
place that serves that student well
well they're consistent nothing makes
sense
by the way Harpeth Hall counts Reese
Witherspoon and Amy Grant as alumni to
people we know for a fact are women
after brief romances
but it makes me wonder what's the point
of a girls school at all you know aside
from the pillow fights would say
dig a good or bad idea
I say to any trans girl who might want
to go there don't hang out with the boys
because I did go to an all-girls
Southern school for a few years and you
don't want to hang out with those
[ __ ]
um
it's what you're no I'm you you
encounter a lot of Magnolia mouths which
is somebody who's drippingly sweet to
your face and then talks heaps of behind
your back right like as soon right but
but not even that it's like you're so
fun I love hanging out with you and then
they call you like donut Doris behind
your back because you smell like Krispy
Kreme
Krispy Kremes
so don't go there
so by the way it's a ploy to get women
in or girls in because these the
enrollment at all these schools is going
because they're horrible places wow you
know it's thick Thicket bread that I
should apply and identify as a young
girl
because if you can I if you can change
your gender without a biological
underpinning why can't you do the same
with age right I know you're in your
what early 60s
but you could probably you could
probably just decide I'm 35 so why can't
I be like what what's the school age for
these girls I didn't read that part
College oh I'm a I'm an 18 year old
incoming uh blonde female yeah why can't
I do that sure why not why can't we do
it together
no why don't we just leave this place
right
listen what are we doing with our lives
I don't know is this where I leave no oh
I stay we leave together
um listen I I identify as thin but I'm
really not
um uh this is where you lose a lot of
the country you lose a lot of Middle
America you lose Hispanic communities
you lose you know Southern Baptist
African-American communities this is
where the disconnect really happens
politically at least where they say what
yeah what is this it's when you you know
Tyrus if you remove the biological uh
reality from life I should be able to
enter the Westminster Dog Show
beat those [ __ ]
oh I would love to walk you yeah I would
love to crawl through those little
tunnels you would probably win I would I
think I would win what's wrong with you
I don't know I'm just I'm just so up
shocked with the sexism of this story
so what's wrong Boys still can't get in
why like that's just not fair yeah just
make it everybody's school this is again
this always they they say things that
don't translate well and what do you do
the first time an assault happens what
do you do the first time these things
happen what do you do with the the girl
that's uncomfortable or the family is
uncomfortable with sharing bathrooms and
showers
you want to you want to celebrate the
individual but you that's everyone it
has to be something other facilities
prepared for this you know because at
the end of the day
a boy who decides to identify as a girl
or whatever and 95 of the time you hope
it's it's a nice healthy situation but
sometimes it's not and we've seen it
we've seen it happen in other schools we
have other situations but again they
don't try to fix problems they say that
like oh we're just going to open it up
if you identify you're in and we're
virtue signaling and we're great but I
did notice it said apply right you can
apply every job that I've ever asked
about where they said well Tyrus you're
welcome to apply
we're not hiring your big ass anytime
soon
but we'll keep your app on file to
remind us not to hire your big ass
anytime that is so true every time I've
been asked oh you can apply nothing ever
happens no nothing ever happens so I
think that's more it just sounds good
you guys all miss the most interesting
part of this what which is this sentence
in cases of non-binary students or those
who use they them pronouns will be
addressed on an individual basis like
what is that basis right they're they
how did those conversations go like what
what some days get in but not other days
yeah and what if like you're a girl but
then you become a vague while you're
there you grandfathered in or do you
have to have
or do you have to have a meeting oh
that'd be interesting if you're
grandfathered in yeah if you're a girl
yeah because you're like okay but if you
are a girl but like now I'm there your
grandmother did do they like bring you
to the do they bring you the off the
office like excuse me we heard that
you're a they now and we need to talk
about if you could still go to school
here like what is maybe they set traps
is there a committee
I don't understand huh got him yeah
it's interesting if you want to pay 33
000 a year and this is what you want for
your life I go ahead I guess yeah if
your checks are clearing they're picking
you out hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else